so i usually have a script to go off of
but today i thought i'd just talk
straight from the heart this isn't the
usual content that i make on this
channel but as we're getting closer to
50 000 subscribers i found myself
thinking about the journey it took to
get to this point and i got pretty
emotional about it to say the least it's
been an absolute grind and saying that
elden ring and more accurately from
software has probably saved my life
isn't too far of a stretch so today i'm
going to talk about my life and my
content creation journey if you're
uncomfortable with discussions about
depression suicidal thoughts addiction
stuff like that then i wouldn't watch
this video and i'll see you all in the
next lore video but if you want to hear
my story then let's get started so ever
since i can remember i've always wanted
to be a content creator i used to prop
up a camcorder and record myself playing
guitar hero back when i was like 10
years old i asked my parents if i could
upload it to youtube which at the time
was a brand new website and they told me
that no one wanted to watch me play
video games so i didn't it really wasn't
cool at all to be into video games back
in those days i'm only 27 now but even
back then i sort of had to hide the fact
that i played video games my friends
really weren't into it yet and my family
just thought it was a waste of time i'm
sure that's not uncommon for a lot of
people that grew up in the early 2000s
along with this i played a ton of golf
my family wasn't rich or anything just
scraping by middle class family and my
parents thought i could go places if i
knew how to play golf so i started
playing when i was 12 my dad would take
me to a cheap driving range for me to
practice at i played junior high school
golf and actually got an offer to play
college golf at a local school i got
some other offers too but i just wanted
to stay close to home because i had been
dating a girl all through high school
and i didn't want to be too far from her
now i was not ready at all to go to
college yet i had no idea what i wanted
to major in yet and took a local offer
to play golf because that's what my
family and i had worked toward my entire
childhood if i didn't get a scholarship
then we couldn't afford college now i
could have just gone to a community
college for free and figured it out then
but i wanted to play golf so i took the
offer close to home for the 2014 school
year now college was not a good time for
me i started getting depressed because i
didn't know how to do things on my own
at this point in my life my first few
days of class i forgot to eat because i
was just running around going to class
in practice all day the life of a
college athlete is not easy you're
either in class you're at practice at a
team study hall team meetings or
required events tournaments all of that
stuff i would miss a ton of class
playing in tournaments and it would
stress me out to no end eventually i
just dropped out of college to join a
pro golf tour in orlando florida i was
out there for about three months before
i injured my right wrist i hit the back
of a tree root on a downswing and to
compare that to something if you don't
know too much about golf it's like
swinging a baseball bat as hard as you
can at a brick wall i actually wound up
doing this two different times since
it's really hard to see the roots under
the straw grass in florida and i've
still got nerve damage in my risk to
this day so i went back home to decide
what to do next also when i came home my
long-term girlfriend broke up with me i
don't want to talk about this too much
but it completely broke my heart but
after this i went to work as an
assistant pro at a local country club
where i'd give people golf lessons and
run the golf shop this was probably the
most depressing job i've ever had since
it paid next to nothing while working
super long hours with little to no
appreciation from the members of the
club but this is when i started
streaming rocket league on twitch after
work so that was kind of nice i saved up
some money to get back out there to play
pro golf and after doing some physical
therapy it took about a year but i went
back to florida but this time i played
in miami i actually stayed in some guy's
refurbished garage in a really sketchy
neighborhood in hollywood florida which
is right next to miami that had decent
internet so i could stream on the side
as well after a month into that i got
robbed at gunpoint while i was just
getting something out of my car in the
driveway they took some things out of
the car and some money from my wallet
but it definitely scared me enough to
just get the hell out of there and find
another place to play i decided to move
all the way out to arizona and they had
some golf tours out there but while
practicing i started having some pain
flare up in my wrist again so i started
some physical therapy training again and
focused on streaming rocket league for a
while i had some success streaming in
early 2019 i was coaching new players
but it definitely wasn't the content
that i wanted to make but it was the
game that i was good at and that i had
played for a few years and i thought
that that's what people wanted at the
time so i just kept doing that i was
completely alone in this apartment in an
area where i had no friends or family
and this is where my depression got a
lot worse it got to a point where i
didn't leave my apartment for well over
a month straight i didn't even go out to
get food or groceries i'd just order
from doordash or instacart and stayed in
my apartment i stopped doing physical
therapy because it didn't seem like it
was getting better
and i just stayed inside streaming i
completely abandoned golf and just spent
all my time streaming and coaching
rocket league i gained about 50 pounds
within just a few months with all of the
fast food and energy drinks i was
consuming on a daily basis and my
depression just obviously got worse and
worse and i'll be honest at this point
i did not want to live anymore i felt
like i had nothing going for me so i
actually planned on how i was going to
commit suicide i won't go into too much
detail about that but i quite literally
packed up all of my things into the
corner of my apartment so it would be
easier for people to get my things out
after they found my body it was really
bad but i decided to go on a hike
through the mountains of arizona and i
told myself that if i still wanted to
die after the hike then i could needless
to say i got to the top of the mountain
after a couple of hours saw a beautiful
sunrise after going super early to avoid
people and i felt a wave of emotions
come over me to put it short i didn't
want to die anymore likely because i was
doing something active outside of my
apartment for the first time in a while
and it felt really good i called my
family i told them everything and my mom
caught the first flight out that she
could so that she could drive all the
way back to missouri with me this was
the start of 2020 and i vowed to myself
to get back out into the world and
experience all it had to offer for me
well we all know what happened in 2020.
basically it was impossible to live up
to that promise i made for myself
because of the pandemic but at least i
was surrounded by family which made it
better than just being alone the first
thing i did when i got back was adopt a
dog her name is joy and she's literally
the best dog i could ever ask for taking
care of her and myself made life so much
more enjoyable i started exercising and
eating right and i can happily say that
i've lost all of that weight and then
some and i'm currently in the best shape
i've ever been in and it feels amazing
there's a lot of things that can cure
depression but in my opinion i think
exercise and just eating correctly
taking care of your body and your mind
is the best way to do it around this
time in 2020 is when a new hot game
called valrant released and i was pretty
addicted to it off the start i decided
to upload a tutorial on a new cool trick
i learned with the character omen
and to put it short it absolutely popped
off a few videos later in a few hundred
thousand views and i was the early omen
maine of valorant on youtube i made
about two dozen videos under the name
jake from state farm and got my channel
to around 20 000 subscribers now that's
not this channel i actually deleted my
valrant channel after just not enjoying
the game anymore and anything else that
i uploaded like a different game
none of my subscribers ever wanted to
see it they would just ask for more
valerian stuff i was a little spiteful
at the time and just deleted the channel
but i just didn't want to play the game
anymore so i didn't really care i went
on a short bout of variety streaming on
twitch just playing random games that i
wanted to play and i found little to no
success with that eventually i went back
to streaming rocket league i felt like
it was the only content i could make
that could be of some value to people
now i didn't want to do this but rocket
league around this time was going free
to play soon so i thought i'd give it
another shot but rocket league
absolutely skyrocketed in popularity
after it went free to play all of a
sudden i was averaging hundreds if not
thousands of viewers during my streams
and i started a tick tock channel where
i'd give like one minute tips that
grossed over 200 000 followers within
just a couple of months i was providing
a ton of educational content to new
players i provided coaching for all of
my subscribers and i eventually hit 2500
paid subscribers on twitch i even got
partnered on twitch for this insane
super fast growth within the rocket
league community i even met a new girl
that i started dating and got my own
really nice apartment in a local area
everything was really looking good for a
while but as some of you may know rocket
league pretty much completely died
shortly after this i won't say too much
on this i just wasn't a big fan of the
super young toxic player base that i was
basically babysitting in my twitch chat
on a daily basis the last straw for me
with rocket league was when i hosted a
rocket league tournament where the
winner would receive 1 000 in prize
money when i gave the money to the
winner they didn't even say anything
they didn't say thank you nothing they
just took the money and completely
disappeared after this i was pissed off
and i just went back to variety
streaming kind of out of spite just
being mad at that situation and i had
thoughts of just giving up on content
creation altogether after this too my
girlfriend thought this was a really bad
idea she thought i should just keep
streaming rockily because that's what
was working and she started acting
really different toward me we had
planned to move in together soon but it
was apparent that she only liked me for
my success on twitch she was pretty much
a gold digger and we broke up and i lost
my lease on the apartment because we
were going to move into a different
apartment within like a couple weeks i
gave up my lease to be in that apartment
and when she decided not to go through
with it i just lost my place to live
pretty much and i definitely couldn't
afford the three-bedroom apartment that
we were going to rent by myself so my
parents were kind enough to let me move
back in with them things were looking
pretty bad and i did not know what to do
then i saw a trailer for elden ring to
release in early 2022 and i can tell you
that all of my hopes came back i had
played every souls game multiple times
over at this point they were my favorite
games i had ever played but they never
did well while i was streaming or making
content with them unless i was already
solidified in the community which i
definitely was not i had streamed every
souls game but like i said they just
didn't do well but eldon ring was a
completely new game and it sent like
from software was marketing the game
more than they usually did with their
previous titles so i started thinking
that with all my experience making
content up to this point it may have
prepared me enough to get on the ground
running when elden ring released from
software also has a very special place
in my heart i played the souls games
over and over and over again to get me
through some of the darkest times of my
life sort of ironic for games called
dark souls during a dark time in my life
i even bought a ps4 just so i could play
bloodborne and sakiro launched around
this time as well they've all been some
of my favorite games i had ever played
and i was so excited for elden ring to
come out especially after some of the
worst game releases in my lifetime i was
so excited about cyberpunk and was
completely disappointed i was also
excited about the last of us too which
was okay in my mind but was met with
some pretty horrible backlash for the
narrative and rightfully so to be honest
but i knew from software just doesn't
make bad games but if they were going to
make a bad game now would have been the
time it just felt like gaming in general
i was losing my love for gaming i just i
was so disappointed by every new release
that came out for you know all of 2020
all of 2021 i just i just couldn't find
love for gaming at this time but we all
know what happened eldon ring launched
and i had the best gaming experience i
had ever had since i played skyrim i
knew i was playing something special as
soon as i defeated godric walked out the
back of the castle and i got this view
this absolutely blew me away with how
big the game really was it's just so
flush with detail in the combat was
exactly what i wanted with a new souls
game and not to mention the deep lore
within the game that i immediately
wanted to understand [ __ ] it took me
about 58 hours to roll credits in my
first playthrough which wasn't even
close to enough time to experience the
full game i didn't even find melania in
my first playthrough i was just confused
since i saw this red-haired girl in the
trailer
and i never found her in the game so i
knew i hadn't explored the entire game
yet but it was my first time playing so
i just didn't know what was all out
there and neither did anybody else i
decided to start a new series on my
youtube channel called lore hunting
where i would explore certain areas and
would just kind of ask questions about
certain things that i would find in
these areas and in my first episode of
doing this i talked about the husk of
godfrey below stormville castle and the
connection it may have had to godfrey
that we see in the deep root depths at
this time none of us even knew this was
godfrey yet but this video has now
grossed over half a million views and
every video i've made since has done so
much better than i ever could have
imagined and here we are almost 50 000
subscribers and i don't plan on stopping
anytime soon it took a lot of work
pain
and sacrifice to get to this point i
taught myself how to edit on photoshop
and edit videos in premiere to make
videos i watched countless youtube
videos on how to be a better streamer
how i could just do everything better in
general for years i did this and if
there's anything that you can take from
this video
it's that it gets better if you continue
to work hard believe in yourself and do
what you love you can absolutely make
your dreams come true what i'm doing now
is my dream job and i can't thank you
all enough for the opportunity to make
content on a game that i love and i know
all of you love too elden rings saved my
love for gaming and my love for creating
content i appreciate the game and what
it's given me which is why i'll continue
to play it and make content for it so
that's it thank you guys for watching
the video i really hope you enjoyed
something a little different and i'll
see you all in the next one take care
[Music]
you